here is an incredible paper that teaches
virtual humans to run in the most
fabulous ways so good so what is this
how did we get here these are large
language models text based AI systems
that can be our smart assistant someone
who can draw images for us we all know
that however fewer fellow Scholars know
that they are excellent at reading and
writing computer code and can us even
learn to play Minecraft that is
incredible just think about it this is a
text based AI how could it possibly
control a graphical game like this
really amazing so at this point we know
what these large language models can do
the age of surprises is over or so I
thought dear fellow Scholars this is
2minute papers with Dr car previous AI
based techniques can play aari games and
other games at a super human level they
typically do it through reinforcement
learning which means that they get a
controller look at the screen and play
like a human wood deep min's techniques
are excellent at this and thus they
already do extremely well on these games
however there is a huge problem what is
the problem well look
scores games have scores and these
scores can be used as feedback for the
AI to understand whether it is doing
well or not high score doing well lower
score not so much and whatever other
task we wish it to perform there needs
to be a score there needs to be feedback
and there in lies the problem each game
has a different scoring mechanis
mechanism and thus each task needs a
different scoring mechanism if we are
aiming to create an intelligence of
sorts any kind of intelligence requires
generality so it has to be able to
perform tasks it hasn't seen before but
how well scientists at Nvidia had a
crazy idea let's use these Chad GPT is
large language models to write code to
calculate the score for these tasks by
itself wow I love it but does it work I
think that cannot possibly work there
are just too many kinds of tasks out
there well let's have a look together
now little AI write code for the score
for this humanoid to run and then train
it wow it works well look no one said it
has to be beautiful we said it has to to
run running is making progress moving
forward it recognized that and this
already works and the whole thing was
written by an AI now get this let's try
some other way first little AI design a
task where forward movement is
necessary wow that is a fabulous way of
moving forward now let's give it some
feedback this looks like Squad jumps
make the movement resemble running a
little more so now the AI says okay got
it so you mean a duck
walk well not quite new feedback the
Torso has to be a little
higher okay good but it is using mostly
one leg to hop on please use both legs
goodness both legs are now being used
but look who oh boy back to square one
now the Torso is too low again let's ask
it to penalize that and there we go
finally something that resembles running
it's not an easy task at all it turns
out and this human feedback driven
solution I think is way better than the
AI on its own this intelligence of sorts
is wonderful but human intelligence is
where it's at what a fantastic paper but
wait it gets better in fact here comes
the best part this concept generalizes
to so many tasks from passing balls to
balancing them teaching robots to move
and even the crowd favorite spinning
pens very impressive but how does this
train so well and so quickly the key is
that this learns within a computer
simulation that has two advantages one
it can't really harm itself and two my
favorite in the real world 1 second
means 1 second but in a virtual world
one second can be simulated much quicker
given a powerful computer a little game
can be simulated quicker how much
quicker well in this case this little AI
is learning a thousand times quicker in
a simulation than in the real world so
cool and and it gets even better hold on
to your papers fellow Scholars because
it can not only match the level of
humans playing these games but the
evolution based variant can even
showcase superhuman performance wow it
matches or exceeds the level of humans
on 75% of dexterity based tasks that is
insanity finally an AI that can do these
tasks and have some some sort of
generality what we are seeing here is
perhaps the early days of true
Intelligence being born and all this
within a little piece of silicon and
lots and lots of human Ingenuity what a
time to be alive however it is a
research work and it is not perfect not
even close for instance please don't ask
it to close your doors ouch if you're
looking for inexpensive Cloud gpus for
AI Lambda now offers the best prices in
the world for GPU Cloud compute no
commitments or negotiation required just
sign up and launch an instance and hold
on to your papers because with the
Lambda GPU Cloud you can now get on
demand h100 instances for just $199 per
hour yes
199 and they are one of the first cloud
providers to offer publicly available on
demand h100 accs did I mention they also
offer persistent storage so join
researchers at organizations like apple
MIT and ctech in using Lambda Cloud
instances workstations or servers make
sure to go to lamb.com
slapers to sign up for one of their
amazing GPU instances today